nicht wundern bei mir saugt das war jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen falsch angefangen
der satz aber ich sage wohl ist bei mir saugt hat jemand im hintergrund nicht wundern
ich hoffe das hat bald erledigt ich habe tür zu aber mehr mehr als tür zu machen kann ich nicht
monach es soll ich zeige euch gleich was wir heute machen bzw. das wir probieren
wir müssen auch so machen dass sie das vielleicht als pull request akzeptieren
fest sie müssen ordentlich ordentliches zeug bauen
heute keine to do ist heute was anderes heute versuchen wir uns mal an einem
github projekt zu kontributen aber ich hoffe dass man nicht viel ändern muss so dass sie das also
die meisten maintainer mögen das nicht wenn du 500 zeilen ändert dass ich hoffe wir kommen
keine ahnung 20 30 zeilen oder so aus so ich mach den kram immer kurz zu ich glaube ich muss
mal wieder update machen yo update update stelle es ist alles ok die ganzen shit zu ich leute ich
ich starte mal die vm neu ich mache jetzt mal ein update und dann starte ich die vm neu ich
bin mir da nicht so sicher leute also zeige euch mal das projekt ich weiß ich ob das vielleicht
leute von euch verwenden also ich habe das mal schon im chat öfters gehört dass das leute von
euch verwenden das ist ja relativ bekannt wir starten das ding auch gleich und ich zeige wobei
ich kann euch die live demo zeigen öfter dir so mal kurz gucken ob hier alles aktualisiert ist
update update so viele updates hier update all starten wir die vm neu aber in der zeit erzähle
ich das mal kurz also das hier ist ein uptime monitor das ist relativ nice ach guck mal man
kann sogar das macht einen neuen neuen account ist ja interessant ist ja schön da kann man das in
ruhe zeigen wahrscheinlich docker instanz die sich resettet oder so
pepo pet das ist das irgendwie gerade die seite ane ok jetzt erst mal erst mal dark
sie einschalten mein michael 5 spiel samar das update zieht gerade meine komplette vm runter
hier guckt euch das mann wie viel was brauchen das java zeug zum updaten wieder guckt euch an
guck mal im sort bei percent cpu so guckt euch das mann dass das java zeug beim update macht
ein komplette cpu dicht so also was das hier ist ich starte das einfach lokal und gut ist
ein pass abschreibe 18 monate massiv moment ich musste sie maus suchen da ist er vorwärts
so also abteilen kuma ist ein monitoring light für daheim nicht wirklich für daheim aber für
welche die nicht so viel infrastruktur haben für welche wo es kein supix kein agios kein check
mk oder sonst was braucht wenn man einfach nur gucken will ob zum beispiel seine raspberry
pies absinnt oder seine zertifikate nicht abgelaufen sind da kann man das damit machen
sieht dann zum beispiel so aus man sagt monitor kann sich aussuchen was man machen will kannst du
damit deinen router überwachen klar du kannst zumindest gucken ob es beispielsweise ssh läuft
ob das webinterface geht oder ob der router generell ab ist also kannst du basic sachen machen wie
hatte tp checks da kannst gucken kommt 200 zurück oder nicht dann kannst du hatte tp check machen
gucken ob in der antwort was drin ist dann kannst du ping ob das ding ab oder down ist und dann
kannst du tcp ports checken ganz dns auflösung machen so und wenn man so was macht was weiß ich
machen wir mal google das ist jetzt relativ offensichtlich dass google da ist kann man es
noch taggen taggen wir mit cute chat sage ich gleich was ich patchen will zeige ich zeige ich
euch gleich und ich glaube es kam was kam was erden so safe so und so sieht das ganze dann aus man
bekommt eine übersicht wie schnell die antwortzeit ist und wann das ding ab und down war und das
schöne ist man kann sich auch eine eine status page anzeigen dass das ist jetzt relativ lahm ich
weiß auch nicht warum wahrscheinlich weil das auf super low end ding gehostet ist so edit status
page und kann man das speichern das kann man dann theoretisch auch wenn man anbieter ist von
irgendwelchen von 34 websites kann man diese seite auch rausgeben an irgendwelche leute für
die man das betreibt da können wieder nachgucken also wirklich sehr monitoring light technisch so
und die haben letztens ein neues feature eingeführt was eigentlich extrem nice ist nämlich webhooks
nennt sich bei den push monitoring so wie das funktioniert ist folgendes ich copy paste mir das
ganze hier mal test dann save ich das so und das funktioniert jetzt so wenn der wir machen mal
einen curl und kopieren uns die kopieren uns kopieren uns das hier rein wenn der das system
was man überwachen will sich nicht innerhalb von 60 sekunden meldet dann geht der check auf rot also
sprich dass es umgedreht normalerweise ist das so ab time kuma guckt ob das system noch auflösbar
ist macht und pink und sonst was push based ist umgedreht die systeme sagen bescheid dass
sie noch da sind und wenn sie nicht innerhalb von einer gewissen zeit bescheid sagen dann sagen sie
dauen so und jetzt sage ich mal bescheid dass ich ab bin und jetzt switch das ding hier auf
können wir noch mal in message angeben pink 12 millisekunden und jetzt switch das auf ab und
wenn ich jetzt wenn ich wenn das system jetzt nicht wieder diesen befehl ausführt innerhalb
von 60 sekunden dann werdet ihr sehen dann geht das automatisch auf rot so und das habe ich bei
mir lokal ich kann ich gucke mal gerade ob ich euch zeigen kann abzahlen da das sei na super ich
weiß mein password nicht aber ich kann es euch so ungefähr zeigen guck das ist so was wie health
check genau mir fehlen aber mir fehlen eigentlich zwei sachen so sieht das bei mir lokal aus status
page mehr habe ich da noch nicht drin und ich kann es euch jetzt auch nicht genau zeigen ja so
sieht das bei mir aus da kann ich überwachen ob die ob der cool champ an ist ob meine raspberry
piles laufen ob die access points laufen sowas in der richtung so wie gesagt ich müsste eigentlich
noch mehr rein machen aber das ist jetzt bei mir lokal erst mal so in der erprobungsphase ich finde
das wirklich cool weil ich habe ich habe lange zeit rum experimentiert bei mir daheim ja von ich
hatte guck jetzt hat er sich innerhalb von 60 sekunden nicht gemeldet jetzt jetzt ist er down
und mir war nagios zu zu eklig zu konfigurieren nagios zu old school und ich hatte ich habe ich
hatte bis zu diesem zeitpunkt wo ich dieses projekt gefunden habe hatte ich nix wo ich
gesagt habe hey das ist mal ganz angenehm lokal einfach als simples monitoring zu verwenden aber
mir fehlen zwei sachen und die eine sache gibt es schon halb mir fehlen zwei sachen wenn man
nämlich ich zeige euch das mal add monitor wenn man nämlich ein htp monitor oder htps monitor
macht aber hier google.de save ja ja google noch mehr google achso ist die lautstärke ok ja dann
und man sich diesen htp check hier jetzt anschaut dann sieht man hier drinne zertifikat expire
geschichten und auch an sachen zu dem zertifikat das ist ganz nice aber die eine sache die mir
fehlt ist dass man sag mal mal zehn tage oder irgendwas was man festlegen kann gibt switch
language für den zapp irgendwas was man selbst festlegen kann dass dann das hier beispielsweise auf
orange geht das weiß ich nicht ob sie das haben wollen weil orange ist eigentlich pending deswegen
muss ich mir da noch was überlegen das mache ich nicht aber das ist das eine was ich gerne hätte
noch was mir wirklich gefallen würde wenn das ding eine eine extra seite hätte für auslaufende
checks also für auslaufende zertifikate so dass das machen wir heute aber nicht so das ist wie
gesagt das eine und das andere was ich gerne hätte ist ich habe manchmal nicht oft so vier
fünf sachen wo ich gerne mehr überwachen würde als ab und da und wo mich der ping auch nicht
wirklich interessiert so zum beispiel drüben im wohnzimmer habe ich eine kiste stehen ping
so ist wieder ab drüben im wohnzimmer habe ich eine kiste stehen die für meine wohner zum
fernsehauf fernsehzeug aufnehmen ist also das ding verwende ich nie aber ich habe trotzdem ganz
gerne ein auge drauf wie viel festplatten platz da frei ist nicht dass das ding auf einmal abkackt
so und jetzt habe ich mir was überlegt wie wäre es denn wenn man mit diesem push notification check
also das wo man hier eigentlich nur sagen kann ab und da wenn man diesen ping craft umfunktionieren
könnte zum beispielsweise einem festplatten auslastung craft das müsste ich habe vorhin
schon mal kurz in den source code reingeguckt das müsste eigentlich relativ einfach sein es
muss unter zwei auflagen passieren erste auflage ist die api darf sich nicht ändern weil da haben
die gerade aktuell überhaupt keinen bock drauf neue api funktion einzuführen und zweitens das
muss möglichst wenig changes einführen weil ansonsten möcht das keiner gerne so und ich
habe mir gedacht wir können das machen relativ easy weil man kann hier eine message mitgeben
und anstatt einfach ihr seht es ja hier an einem message anstatt einfach den text mitzugeben hier
mit message ok oder keg weh oder sonst was als message könnte man da ein json objekt mit schicken
wo dann sowas drinne steht zum beispiel wie description und unit und wenn es gesetzt ist
dann tauscht er das ping einfach aus durch description und den craft tauscht er dann
einfach auch nur die demo vorbei tauscht er dann einfach auch nur die über das overlay aus weil
der ping craft ist ja vollkommen ok man kann ja ping weiter für den wert verwenden stellt euch
mal vor man könnte sowas machen ich weiß dass es nicht geht weil es nicht unencoded ist stelle
euch mal vor man könnte ne post geht nicht post post funktioniert nicht außerdem das back end
speichert die message einfach nur als string das ist kann es nichts machen stelle ich mal vor man
könnte sagen ich weiß dass das nicht unencoded ist aber nur so theoretisch stelle ich mal vor man
könnte sagen unit keine ahnung gb description keine ahnung disk irgendwie sowas irgendwie mal
gucken muss muss man was überlegen weil wahrscheinlich braucht man wahrscheinlich braucht man die unit
gar nicht doch die unit braucht man sonst ist das doof irgendwie sowas ja und hier setzt man dann
was weiß ich 450 g oder vielleicht soll man es disk 3 nennen und und das schickt man ab und dann
kann man anstatt komischen ping einfach den den den craft verwenden nicht für ping weil ganz
ehrlich was interessiert mich der ping bei einem bei einem push check von in der internen kiste von
die permanent sich um milli sekunde dreht sowas in der richtung das versuchen heute einzubauen
so was ich jetzt mal machen würde ist gucken ob es irgendwelche updates gibt und mal meine
kiste neu starten ich weiß nicht was das was für schmerzen hat und das müsste eigentlich gehen
post geht nicht aber post würde uns auch nichts bringen weil die haben ein express gs back end
habe ich schon vorher nachgeguckt und die api nimmt halt nun mal nur zwei optionen an ich
zeige euch auch gleich schon mal die github issues da sind andere leute auf ähnliche
ideen gekommen warum nicht grafana weil grafana für so einfaches up und down komplizierter ist
für grafana brauchst du irgendwas um deine metriken einzusammeln grafana ist ja nur das
dashboard du brauchst bei grafana irgendwas um deine metriken einzusammeln sei es jetzt
irgendwas was in flux db schreibt oder prometoids oder sonst was dann musst du deine queries bauen
für grafana dann brauchst du theoretisch noch irgendwas sowas wie alert manager wenn ihr das
eingebaute zeug nicht reicht und einfaches up und down monitoring ist auch nicht so schön mit
grafana zumal man das ja eigentlich damit prometoids alert manager rules machen müsste oder aber du
bräuchtest zwei systeme nämlich ein system für abdauen und eins mit grafana für die festplatten
auslastung das ist genauso wie ich es gerade habe das ist genauso wie ich es gerade habe ich habe
ein grafana so plattenplatz und dann sieht man den plattenplatz so aber ich hätte das gerne also
ich denke da könnten auch alle davon profitieren wenn es wenn es die zwei sachen gebe eine seite
wo man sieht die zertifikate die auslaufen oder ist ein bisschen schöner gehighlightet und dass
man diese sachen die dort eingebaut sind für den pin kraft man für was anderes benutzen kann das
wäre schon extrem nice und ich habe mal hier geguckt es sind schon ein paar andere auf auch
auf die idee gekommen dass es cool wäre was bisschen mehr einzubauen in diese push notifications ja
der hier zum beispiel hat gestern erst in pull request gestellt für dass er den status gerne
setzen würde aktuell ist es ja so entweder der check meldet sich oder das ding timeout und es
geht auf dauen und er sagt wie wäre es wenn man den status einfach so setzen könnte so und das war auch
so mein einstieg da habe ich nämlich einfach mal vorhin in den in dem seinen pull request
reingeguckt viel mehr habe ich noch nicht gemacht ich habe ich habe in seinen pull request reingeguckt
hat mir gedacht das sieht eigentlich alles relativ übersichtlich aus weil man auch hier irgendwie
so ein configuration objekt hat und sowas das kriegen wir das kriegen wir vielleicht gebacken
das einzubauen aber da müssen wir mal gucken das müssen wir mal schauen also wir müssen uns den
graben erst mal klonen und dann probieren wir mal ich habe gesehen der hat irgendwo so ein wiki
gehabt wo drin steht wie man development startet damit deff set up oder so ne
set up development genau mein leute so und von der das habe ich mir vorhin schon mal angeguckt von
der idee hier ich brauche noch js größer 14 habe ich no lease license file warum habe ich hier
überhaupt ein package json in meinem pack wait alter was macht es denn da was macht es in meinem
home verzeichnis hier weg das muss das hat er nichts zu suchen leider ist er aktuell mit
anderen projekten beschäftigt und deswegen kann es so lange mörschrequests kommen ja gut kann
man nichts machen kann man nichts machen kann ich mir keine übel nehmen aber ich werde das
deswegen versuche ich auch möglich das so klein zu halten vom patch was irgendwie geht dass man
vielleicht sieht ok das macht nichts schlimmes oder aber dass ich bei mir einfach benutzen kann
bis es dann irgendwie eine ablehnt oder anehmt oder keine ahnung ich will es mir mal angucken
doch also noch erst haben wir am start
ach du hast schon viel dazu eingereichert das ist nice gut gut zu wissen ich muss mir das jetzt
erst einmal angucken ich habe gar keine ahnung großartig von ich habe bisher nur gesehen dass
es im future ist front etwas ganz gut finde damit kenne ich mich wie gesagt aus und irgendwie
express back end aber in diesem back end muss ich nichts machen und ich habe nämlich auch gelesen
auf github dass sie nicht so scharf drauf sind gerade dass man irgendwelche neuen apis einführt
oder sowas deswegen versuche ich das alles in die schon vorhandenen mal ein bisschen rein zu
rein zu quetschen nochmal gucken wie das funktioniert wir müssen jetzt erst mal klonen
also man braucht was ich gesehen habe ist man braucht sq light unter den contributors
was ist das ich dachte man kommt jetzt auf die github ich dachte man kommt jetzt von dir auf
dein github profil das ist das ist nicht gut lesbares wegen dark theme sponsoring ist das
ne achso ja dann klonen wir das ding mal benutzt ein node version manager nee habe ich jetzt nicht
gebraucht also ich weiß dass man nvm da easy für verwenden kann das ist nicht so als hätte ich
nicht schon verwendet aber aktuell nicht aktuell komme ich eigentlich gut klar mit dem system node
so da ist es so jetzt müssen wir mal schauen wie das funktioniert contribution so npm ci also
man braucht noch ges größer 14 habe ich ich habe 17 ist schon was und sq light habe ich
alles am start also installieren wir das mal gucken weiter habe ich nicht geguckt also ich
habe von dem code keine großartige ahnung ich habe mir nur den pull request angeguckt von dem
einen und es ist im vgs frontend das weiß ich mir nicht so ach ja ok es ist leute ich vergaß es
ist ein javascript projekt wir müssen mal wieder wir müssen das komplette internet installieren
dass es funktioniert das ist ja wieder typisches typisches node projekt aller 1260 packages alles
klar ok how to start backend server bäm oh knacks was zum teufel ist knacks ich weiß
ihr was ich glaube wir machen uns einen docker container mit irgendeinem aktuellen demian oder
sonst was drauf dass ich hier meiner maschine nicht so viel rumwürsten muss necks was hat knacks
für schmerzen cannot find module es knacks nicht dieses ps4 spiel ja das ist das ist das ist das
ps4 release ps4 spiel was niemand spielen wollte frage welchen hypervisor nutze hast du empfehlung
für eine vm performanz zu machen ja vor allem bei workstation ja ich habe windows als haus
vor allem bei workstation für linux vms und für alle anderen geschichten warum eigentlich
npm ci weil das hier steht die dortfile sind halbwegs aktuell ja halbwegs so was ist jetzt
das problem knacks trace error knacks wir googeln noch danach aber ich glaube wir machen
uns in den docker container zum cannot find knacks knacks was los was knacks
next als space für sein red red bean node was zum teufel ist red bean node ich kenne mich im
node ökosystem nicht sonderlich gut aus aber es sollte ja es sollte ja zumindest lauffähig
sein ohne größere geschichten ne cannot find sq light habe ich nicht ich hab
wisst ihr was wir machen uns in docker wir machen uns demian docker container oder so
ich glaube die verwenden auch demian für ihr standard standard image da wissen auf
jeden fall dass der kram funktioniert das steht cannot find sq ne ne ne ne ne da
sagt cannot find module blablabla sqlite und sqlite habe ich ja installiert sqlite 3 kein
ding pap sqlite werde ich ja wohl kaum installieren müssen vielleicht irgendwas für node oder so
wir machen uns einfach in demian container fertig da jetzt kein nerf drauf da ewig trau
um zu wurschteln steht ja sogar da npm i- ne ne ne ne da steht da was er versucht zu machen was
dann aber aus irgendwelchen gründen fehlschlägt ich mein wir können mal von hand probieren ob es
funktioniert ach wisst ihr woran das liegen könnte ich habe doch in meinem npm drin stehen dass der
keine scripts ausführt braucht man das dafür ne ging auch so jetzt hat es funktioniert run
okay wir probieren das demian container weil die verwenden auch demian base hier für ihr
bild standardmäßig docker minus er nicht ach du scheiß docker zeug docker run it bash demian
docker kommandos keg weight alter ist es demian bash was umgedreht es ist nicht it run
ach es ist minus it dann ist ja alles gut was hältst du dir von programmieren bootcamps
oder so coachings oder lieber selbst denn keine ahnung ich war wieder in einem bootcamp noch habe
ich ein coaching bisher bekommen jemals irgendwann ist das einzige was ich gemacht habe das hat aber
in der richtung nix mit nix mit lernen zu tun wir haben mal so einen coding camp auf der arbeit
gemacht wo es um irgendwie innovative neue apps ging und wisst ihr war im ende gewonnen hat nicht
die leute mit einem ordentlich funktionierenden prototyp sondern die die nix gemacht haben außer
zwei tage irgendeine komische präsentation ich meine klar ich verstehe präsentation ist wichtig
ja aber geht es bei einem bei so einem camp rein um um präsentieren dann hätte man das gleich sagen
müssen erscheinen hat sein funktioniert ich ich habe übrigens noch was noch was vergessen
ach du scheiße was habe ich nie alles am start also docker run minus minus name
cute chat so ports brauchen wir welche ports 3.000 oder sowas 3.000 vue js und ja 3001 ok
port 3000 port als die musik ein bisschen laut mario kart heute hier alter jetzt soll ich abend
essen bestellen ich fasse es nicht soll abendessen bestellen dass um 19 Uhr da ist jetzt ok ich
mache das ich mache es jetzt vom zweiten rechner aus das kann jetzt aber echt gebrauchen ok ok
sagt leute lieferando ihr müsst jetzt mal kurz tapfer sein ihr kriegt nichts mit bestellt selber
kochen so also was will ich denn haben burger menus so was nehmen wir denn
was zum
was ist das
wir haben ihre webseite geändert der laden wo ich immer bestellt warum ist die webseite jetzt
anders jetzt kann ich ja gar nicht das bestellen was ich immer bestellen will was ist denn hier
los anzeige ist raus chat ich gucke gleich ich ich gucke gleich in chat rein ach ja ok also
beef bacon burger menü halal wie kann denn ein beef burger menü halal sein ergibt das
irgendwie sinn ist halal nicht kein schweinefleisch und ist bacon nicht automatisch schweinefleisch
groove elektrik dankeschön für den sub
ich muss ok also das bestellen wir jetzt einmal mit grautsalat und pommes frites zack dann
dann ein chicken breast filet burger es ist bei drei personen leute also jetzt nicht alles
für mich ja chicken breast filet burger grautsalat pommes frites jawoll
so und was mache ich als letztes beef bacon ach nee warte mal beef bacon bedeutet das
ist bacon aus kuh oder was bacon
das nehmen wir noch das noch mit pommes frites und grautsalat zack
so 27 euro bin ich jetzt nee sogar noch mehr keckweight alter 34 euro für burger wtf
ok etage
telefonnummer lieferzeit 19 uhr paypal
paypal bezahlen ok ja das hätte ich vorm stream machen sollen
habe ich sorry leute habe ich habe ich verkackt
paypal einloggen meine güte
jawoll 34 euro 34 euro 17 jetzt bezahlen ganz schön teuer oder 34 euro 17 für drei burger
menus so leute bestellung ist raus ich habe es geschafft ich muss mal kurz jetzt euch ganz
schnell ausmachen bevor wir wieder anfangen da ich nix copy pastet hatte rüber in die vm von adresse
und so habe ich nicht alles klar gut ok wunderbar auf geht's ok wo sind wir stehen geblieben also
noch mal ganz schnell ganz schnell chat gucken ob ich irgendwas mit wie vor sage ich nicht was
ist das für ein linux das du benutzt manjaro mit e3 wm ich kenne ich kenne die vier feine
der deutschen bahn ich kenne frühling sommer herbst und winter ich habe nix zu sehen leute
wenn ich irgendwas übersehen habe im chat sach sach bescheid also so also wir brauchen port 3000
port 3001 und dann sollten wir vielleicht noch irgendein verzeichnis mappen mk dir temp immer
besser besser name für alles home max repos temp wird gemapt auf root wir machen in dem
repo wir machen in dem container einfach alles auf root warum sollte man jemals was anderes machen
so es ist es ist minus it da sind wir unser container ist am start gucken wir mal ob das
mappen vom container funktioniert hat repo temp tatsch1 ja ach nee moment slash root habe ich
auch tatsch1 ok funktioniert m1 warum kann ich das löschen leute warum kann ich die datei löschen
obwohl obwohl die datei root gehört muss ich das jetzt verstehen irgendwie ach ja aber leute ich
bin heute abend wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich da um 24 uhr oder so mache ich noch mal streben an oder vorher schon mal gucken ich habe
eh nichts besseres zu tun wupp countdown genau ok also jetzt können wir anfangen
was brauchen wir dann erst mal ab update im container machen hoffentlich funktioniert das im container jetzt
ordentlich so ab install node js npm wobei es ist npm bei node.js dabei nee das ist debian das ist nicht
dabei white debian login ab install node hit git und sqliteprom Terran
oder klonen wir uns das ganze und schon aber du ich muss mir angewöhnt eben müssen wir müssen
das immer auch erzählt ich muss ich muss mehr trinken im stream und krieg ich trocken awakend
mit der Halswischke, Kopfhörn, alles, dass es sackt, warum nicht, gibt es kein aktuelles
Container Image oder warum das Update im Container, ähm, weil ich zusätzliche Sachen zählen
muss, dass ich das auschecken kann, dass das lauffähig ist, oh was ist denn beim aktuellen
Debian überhaupt für eine Node Version dabei, na super das ist zu alt, Node, äh nicht Node,
Abt, Achtsch, Node, JS und NPM, ja Debian ist immer, ähm, install Debian Node, da gab
es doch wieder sowas schönes, was man nach Bashpipen konnte, weil wir alle wissen, ist
prinzipiell nach Bashpipen immer die beste Variante, sowas da, genau, nach Bashpipen
ist immer die beste Variante, irgendwas zu installieren, ich mein wir können auch einfach
NPM, äh, NPM verwenden.
Was genau ist deine Anwendung für Uptime, Kuma, kann ich dir zeigen, also lokal verwende
ich das dafür, zum Beispiel um zu checken, das ist das falsche, äh, um, nein es ist
falsch, es ist, Haus nicht Maus, Alter, so, Stats Page, da hab ich zum Beispiel meine
Access Points drinne, die, äh, die Raspberry Pis, paar ESPs und ein paar andere Kisten,
also ich sehe, wenn irgendwas abkackt, ich hab übrigens auch nicht alles geändert, seh
ich grade, es aber auch nicht so wild ist, so, was ist denn das LTS Release aktuell,
wir können das mit, wir machen das Upt Install NPM, gibt es das nicht, Upt Search, Node Version
Manager oder so, ach, Debian, wie heißt das Zeug denn, NVM, ach komm, wisst ihr was,
mir nehmen wir einfach das neueste Node, bam, Upt Install, Curl, S und Bash, so wie man
es machen sollte, einfach schöne Sachen aus dem Internet, immer als Root nach Bashpipen,
äh, jawoll, mach ich auch, ne, mach ich net, alles, da machen wir, Build Essentials wollen
wir noch installieren, Build Essentials, gut, oh ne, wo ist das Problem, wa,
ne, wo ist, wo ist so ein Problem, wo, was hat er für Schmerzen,
update, Upt Install Node Chairs, hä, hä, jetzt gehts oder was, na gut, ist
der Raspberry Pi ATC nicht intern, doch ist er, ja, das läuft daheim, ja, nä, nä, noch,
noch bei weitem nicht alles, aber so hab ich mir das mal gedacht, deswegen fänd ichs
auch besonders cool, wenn der noch Zertifikat, die Zertifikate, die ablaufen, ordentlich
anzeigen könnte und dass man so Sachen wie, äh, Festplattenauslastung irgendwie rein
bekommt und das geht ja jetzt schon über Push Monitoring, da waren noch alte Node Sachen
da, ok, so, ähm, Node, Minusminus Version, alles klar, GitHub, Git, clone, Git Cloner,
alles schneller, Uptime, haben wir das hier, wunderbar, äh, npmce war es, ne, haben da,
hat er geschrieben, npmce und dann das da, so, jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, ob das im Container
ordentlich funktioniert, ob das an irgendwelchen Arch By The Way Geschichten liegt, dass es
nicht funktioniert hat, die Card-Steel liegt unten irgendwo rum, ok, so, mal schauen, ob
es geht, chat, was meint ihr, funzt das jetzt im Debian-Container, also ich persönlich tippe
auf ja, das funktioniert, weil der offizielle Container auch auf Debian basiert, sag's nein,
ja, wenn es dann, wenn es nicht geht, wenn es nicht geht, müssen wir wahrscheinlich
irgendwie Git, Git Versions, äh, paar Git-Comments resetten und gucken, ob es dann funktioniert,
alles wahrscheinlich einfach hier im, im Master-Branche, oh, sorry, Main-Branche, mal gucken,
Master, ah, gut, bin ich auch vollkommen in Ordnung, bei mir heißen die Dinge auch noch
überall Master und bis jetzt war noch keiner geträgert und funktioniert, listening, excellent,
ich muss nochmal abbrechen, apt install tmux, so, run und jetzt das frontend noch runnen,
das frontend runnen mit npm run def, alles klar, so, wenn ich jetzt richtig gemacht hab,
alles mit meinem Docker-Container-Kram, dann sollte, ich mein, es macht mir schon zuversichtlich,
dass da oben was steht, wunderbar, so, username, admin, Passwort 123456, das ist zum testen,
ok, ah, wunderbar, äh, settings, erstmal das Allerwichtigste, das Ganze auf dark mode
stellen, Dashboard, gut, wunderbar, da haben wir es am Start, so, add monitor, ein Push-Monitor,
den nennen wir mal test, kopieren wir uns die Uhr, alle 60 Sekunden soll das Ganze was
machen und sagen save, schieben wir auf Desktop 3, dann machen wir auch gleich unser Visual
Studio auf, so, das werden wir jetzt nicht bearbeiten können, wir machen jetzt die Hardcore-Variante,
chmod 777, uptime, bam, ach ne, sudo, ja, gib ihm, 0, sehr gut, erstmal einfach, einfach
schreib und lesbar für alle, aber nachdem es eh nur bei mir lokal ist, ist es ja auch
vollkommen egal, so, und jetzt können wir da hin und können sagen Visual Studio Code
starten, ne, falscher Ordner, äh, wo liegt da eigentlich die Anwendung drin, wenn der
Docker crash war alles umsonst, ne, deswegen hab ich das doch hier gemapped, äh, wo ist
denn die Anwendung drin, ne, Server nicht, gibts client, frontend, www, source, ne, doch
source wahrscheinlich, für was benutzt man uptime, Kuma, um zu überprüfen, ob deine
Kisten noch laufen, guck, ach ne, ich will keine Demo, ich will euch das Bild zeigen,
so, zum Beispiel, kannst du überprüfen, ob deine Kisten noch laufen und kriegst dann
sogar auch ne Anzeige, wann Zertifikate ablaufen und sowas, so, das ist wirklich gut, wie gesagt,
das reicht für mich daheim voll und ganz aus, klar auf der Arbeit haben wir nen Zappix
am Start und wir haben auch relativ viel Prometos-Monitore mit Grafana vorne dran mittlerweile
für Metric-Geschichten, aber für mich daheim ist das wunderbar, es muss bloß noch zwei
Sachen können, dann wär ich echt komplett happy, ne ordentliche Übersicht-Seite für
Zertifikate und die Möglichkeit das ganze irgendwie mit Parametern zu pushen, dass man
beispielsweise auch Festplatten-Auslastungen anzeigen könnte, natürlich, mir ist klar,
die Notifications funktionieren dann nicht und sowas, aber, ja, mal gucken, wie Monitore
als Server auf dem Uptime-Kuma läuft, ja, das ist so ein Ding, ne, Monitoren als Monitoring.
So, Source, hier sind wir, schieben wir das mal ein bisschen rüber, mal kurz kleiner,
was ist das eigentlich für ne Schriftgröße hier, 100% sollte mal reichen.
So, Köl, pushen wir mal, dass es ab ist, nicht funktioniert, achso, Quoten, okay, Check
ist ab, so, jetzt müssen wir uns was überlegen, ernsthaft, mit 39 Monitoren ist der schon
bei dir an der Limit, wirklich, weil SQLite ist ja an sich, wenn das alles nur von einer,
also SQLite ist doch eigentlich in der Regel immer ganz gut, solange du da nicht Multithreaded
Dinger machst oder Multiple Rides parallel und sowas machen willst, SQLite doch normalerweise
absolut in Ordnung, weil es ist ja nicht mal so, dass 39 Monitore da wahnsinnig viel
reinschreiben würden oder so, ich mein klar, wenn du 39 Dinger einmal pro Sekunde updaten
lässt, aber selbst dann, also wie gesagt, der Preischamp hat auch SQLite im Hintergrund
und da waren teilweise, gut, das macht nicht so viel, das liefert statische Sachen aus
und zieht ein bisschen historische Daten zur Grafikkartenpreisentwicklung, aber es ist
auch SQLite im Hintergrund, by the way, Ausrufenzeichen Hetzen, wer sich noch 20 Euro Startgut haben
sichern will, bis heute Nacht geht das Ganze noch und da waren irgendwie teilweise am Anfang
irgendwie 800 Leute gleichzeitig drauf oder so, das hat funktioniert, der Preischamp,
jeder geht morgen offline, das schalte ich nicht um 0 Uhr ab, ich denke eigentlich SQLite
ist wunderbar dafür, da kann man das nämlich einfach starten und es funktioniert, ohne
dass man irgendwelche Connectionsachen konfigurieren muss oder sonst was, ich mein vielleicht
optional SQLite oder Postgres, Postgres wäre mir persönlich lieber, aber trotzdem, es
ist komisch, dass das abkackt, na gut, also, ping, bam, so und jetzt muss ich mir mal den
Source Code hier ein bisschen angucken, ja, also ich hab mir das so überlegt, man könnte
diese Message hier missbrauchen, um mehrere Daten hoch zu pushen, weil ab hier ändern
möchte der Autor, also der, wie heißt das, Projektgründer aktuell nicht, was ich auch
verstehen kann, deswegen gucken wir, dass wir irgendwelche Chasen Zeug übergeben können
und möglichst ordentlich und möglichst wenig Änderungen, mal gucken, so, wir basteln uns
mal ne Schleife drum herum, while, true, true, wir übergeben jetzt einfach mal ein paar
random Werte, dass wir sehen, dass was passiert, keine Ahnung, random, echo, random, ping,
random, sleep, 20, done, machts jetzt was, ja, Funst, funktioniert, so, das brauche ich,
dass ich sehe, dass irgendwas passiert, ok, jetzt gucken wir uns den Source Code von dem
Teil mal an, also, AppView, was gibt's da, ah, ich hab keine Vue.js, wie hieß das Ding,
Vola oder so, glaub das ist es, das ist das glaube ich das aktuelle empfohlen für Vue.js
3, wobei ich glaub das ist noch ein Vue.js 2, oder, glaub schon, jetzt haben wir Syntax
Highlighting, das reicht, ohje, ich hoffe mein Visual Studio formatiert den Scheiß nicht
um beim Speichern, sieht nicht so aus, das wäre blöd, das muss ich auf jeden Fall um,
das kann ich auch immer absolut nicht haben, wenn Leute standardmäßig andere Editor-Settings
haben, also, als ich haben und dann erstmal jede Seite, die sie kommenden umformatieren,
weil ihre Settings besser sind, so, also App ist der Einstieg, da passiert nicht sonderlich
viel, Dashboard 1, ok, Pages, Dashboard, ne, Dashboard 1, warte mal, wo sind denn die
Routen überhaupt, mal gucken, also Absorber will ich nix ändern, ob das irgendwie hinhaut,
versuch das möglichst, möglichst minimalistisch alles zu machen, sodass nix breakt, was aktuell
geht und dass möglichst wenig geändert wird, ach hier, Router, so, Dashboard, Dashboard
ID ist die Seite, Dashboard ID, leht was, Empty Layout, ah ne, Dashboard Home, Component,
Details, Edit, geht mal davon aus, dass wir Dashboard Home brauchen, was war das, Dashboard
Home und Details, irgendwie noch, ne, Details, das da, gut, ihr wisst ihr was, testen wir
das doch einfach mal, hallo, wo sind wir auf der Seite, aha, wir sind schon mal richtig,
wir haben es richtig gefunden, guck mal, wenn wir hier was ändern, der Scheiß da, wir sind
im richtigen Pfeil, ist schon mal gut, Moment, hat das jetzt umformatiert, ach ne, please,
hör auf Sachen umzuformatieren, Wishful Studio Code, wie kann man, wie kann man Auto Format
und Save abschalten, das will ich nicht, Auto Format und Save, Auto Format, Settings, Format,
Format und Save, weg, weil, da hab ich wirklich keinen Bock drauf, dass, dass ich hier das
komplette Ding zerschieße, nur weil mein Wishful Studio der Meinung ist, oh wir formatieren
jetzt mal ein bisschen um, das ist so easy, kein Problem, Git Status, was, warum ist das
alles modified, was, ach so, chmod, oh ich noob, ich hab alles ch und, das war keine so
cleffere Idee, Pfeil Fart Time, na gut, das kann man alles rückgängig machen, Git Reset
Minus Minus Hard Bam, ok, aber jetzt hab ich ja keine Rechte mehr, jetzt hab ich ja keine
Rechte mehr, ok, wie krieg ich das jetzt, Big Brain Time, ok, wie krieg ich, wie krieg
ich das jetzt hin, ja chown hab ich eben auch schon gemacht, ich mein, ich kanns wieder
chownen, ach so chown auf mich, ja das würde funktionieren, kann da ne Docker überhaupt
da drinnen noch rumwursten, ich hoffe mal, ich hoffe mal, stimmt, ich mach einfach auf
mein User, easy, genau, jaja, ich mach einfach auf mein User, easy, haha, wunderbar, insufficient
Permissions, warum, bin ich nicht in meiner eigenen, bin ich nicht in meiner eigenen Usergruppe
oder was, ok, vielleicht muss ich auch nochmal neu öffnen, was haben denn die, was haben
die da Teilen für Rechte, ach so, die haben für Group no Read, ok, wisst ihr was, ich
hoffe dann geht das Docker Zeug noch danach, ok, ok, scheint noch alles zu funktionieren,
gut, so, ich hoffe jetzt funzt alles, ok, ich kann speichern, gut, wunderbar, gut, auf
gehts, also, Dashboard war aber schonmal richtig, ok, das funktioniert auch noch, so, also ich
mach das jetzt erstmal nur rein optisch, wie ich mir vorstelle, dass das funktionieren
könnte, also, wenn man zum Beispiel jetzt diese Push Notifications schickt, ganz ehrlich,
der Ping ist ja gut, wenn das Default mäßig ist, aber man müsste den Ping ja einfach auch
als was anderes verwenden können, dass man zum Beispiel dann sagt, hier, das ist nicht
Ping, sondern das ist Disk Space Gigabyte oder sowas, das heißt wo ist das alles, Ping,
Stats, Heartbeat List, klingt schon mal ganz gut, Monitor Up, Important Heartbeat List,
müssen wir vielleicht in Details gucken, Details, ah hier guckt mal, Value Ping, hallo, hallo,
hallo, jawoll, Ping Title, das ist doch schon mal gut, Ping Title ist eine Methode, ok,
Ping Title, ich mein von der Idee her, ah das ist sogar richtig Big Brain Leute mit Translations,
mit Translations, da kann Ping übersetzt werden, gibt es hier irgendeine Sprache wo Ping nicht
Ping heißt, na gut, wahrscheinlich in Chinesisch, er kommt ja glaube ich aus Hongkong, der Erfinder
davon, das heißt dann halt nicht Ping, sondern, frag mich nicht, Zeichen die Ping bedeuten,
so was ist denn wenn ich jetzt sage, Return, Kekwe, dann heißt Ping einfach nur noch Kekwe,
das ist gut, so und da könnte man dann sowas reinschreiben wie ein Disk, GB, das muss man
halt irgendwie dynamisch übergeben, so, sowas wäre dann zum Beispiel schon mal ganz schick,
so und dann müssen wir gucken wie man die Unit hier rein kriegt, aber funktionieren
tut das alles, weil der Graph und so da ändert sich ja überhaupt nichts dran, es ändert
sich eigentlich nur das Label, Disk, das mit Uptime ist vollkommen ok, Disk, ok das switcht
jetzt wieder zurück auf Millisekunden, ok ja klar, wenn es ein Update kriegt, warum switcht
es zurück auf Millisekunden, ok, ach ne, ne passt doch, wir haben doch gar nichts geändert,
wo kommt denn das hier her, dann machen wir das mal wieder weg, dass ich es besser finde
auf der Seite, Ping, Ping, Ping Title hat er doch unten irgendwo gehabt, Count Up, Components,
Count Up, ah guckt mal hier, in weiser Voraussicht gibt es da schon ein Unit, das ist doch wunderbar,
was passiert denn jetzt zum Beispiel, wenn man hier mal reinschreibt, Unit ist Gigabyte,
passiert nix, ach Moment, das muss man ja counten, ah ja jetzt ist Unit Gigabyte, wunderbar
und dann hier wahrscheinlich genauso, ok, da sind auf jeden Fall schon mal die Stellen,
wo man was ändern muss und jetzt ist das einzige, was noch übrig bleibt, wo man was ändern
müsste, also diese zwei Stellen und ich mein schön ist es nicht, dass wir das Pingfeld
dafür missbrauchen, vielleicht sollte man einfach noch einen weiteren Value setzen können,
wobei dann weiß ich, wenn man das geschickt schickt, ich benutze jetzt erstmal Ping dafür,
so und jetzt müssen wir Response Time irgendwie noch ändern, Chart, Ping Chart, Components,
Ping Chart, Line Chart, hier Resp Time, Resp Time, das müsste das hier sein, null, ja wunderbar,
also Resp Time können wir reinschreiben, wenn die Default Unit ist, ansonsten schreiben
wir, wobei gibt es hier überhaupt auch eine Unit, ach ne da gibt es keine Unit, machen
wir einfach mal eine Unit, String, ach jetzt habe ich ja kein Autoformat mehr, Require
Falls auf jeden Fall und Default Millisekunden, Alter, ja wir haben jetzt Kirby, das ist das
Kirby-E-Mode, so und dann könnten wir hier unten gucken, da wo Response Time drin steht,
quasi wenn Unit, wenn Unit, gibt es sowas wie Default, gibt es einen Check, wenn Unit
Default, wenn Unit Millisekunden ist, dann Response Time und ansonsten, näher nicht
wirklich Unit, sondern das was als Description übergeben wird, äh warum ist das jetzt weg,
Unit, Unit sollte Millisekunden sein, hä, warum ist Unit nicht Millisekunden, ich hab
es da oben gesetzt, was anderes wird doch überhaupt nicht benutzt, warum, warum ist
das nicht, wenn Unit Millisekunden, hä, das muss doch Millisekunden sein, wieso, was ist
denn, Unit, Unit ist doch MS, hä, wie jetzt funktioniert es auf einmal, ok ich hätte einfach
nur reloaden müssen, jetzt funktioniert es, ok wenn Unit MS ist, dann Response Time, ansonsten
die die wir von Hand setzen, müssen wir mal gucken wie man das, wie man das rein kriegt,
ok, ich meine das sind nur drei Zeilen die ich geändert habe bis jetzt, so Ab Count
ist alles in Ordnung, Unit, Default, ja, jetzt, ok, jetzt ist die Preisvorlage, das ist eigentlich
alles was ich ändern muss, wenn ich den Ping Graph für was anderes missbrauchen will,
ähm, dann ist es ja nicht mehr der Ping Graph, dann ist es ja dann der, was weiß ich, Festplatten-Auslastungsgraph
oder was auch immer, die Sache ist jetzt plus die, wie kriegen wir die Infos was wir haben
wollen da rein, ich meine das wäre den Ping Value, ich meine schöner wäre es natürlich,
ganz ehrlich, schöner wäre es natürlich, wenn man anstatt Ping einen extra, ähm, einen
extra Feld Value hätte, aber ich ja noch habe auf GitHub gelesen, das ist, also gerade
neue API Sachen sind sie nicht scharf drauf, dann nehmen wir halt Ping oder wir machen es
als JSON Objekt in die Message oder sowas, jetzt ist die Frage, wie können wir die Settings
einstellen, dass der das checkt, dass das kein, dass das kein Ping ist, sondern dass
das ein, was weiß ich, Gigabyte für Festplatten ist, gibt es ein, gibt es in diesem, ok, mal
Edit, wie, wie wird denn die Config gehandelt für die einzelnen Checks, Edit, Edit, da
müssen wir mal die Edit Komponente angucken, das ist wahrscheinlich hier, Edit, wahrscheinlich
ist es Edit Monitor, würde ich jetzt einfach mal raten, wir können mal in die, wir können
mal in die Routes rein gucken, was es ist, Slash Edit, Edit Monitor, ja, wie funktioniert
das denn hier überhaupt, gibt es dann irgendwie so ein pro Check gespeichertes Config JSON
oder, ne, das kann nicht sein pro Check gespeichertes Config JSON, weil, das gibt ja wahrscheinlich
für jede Config Eintrag in eine Datenbank fällt im Backend, da wird nicht einfach irgendwie
JSON reingedumpt, vermute ich jetzt einfach mal, Friendly Name, ja, Save, wir müssen einfach
mal gucken, was unter Save passiert, Save Button, Button, Alp Submit, wo ist die Form dafür,
Submit, ok, da hätte ich jetzt auch drauf kommen können, ok, This Processing Input
Beautify JSON Format, ok, anscheinend ist das JSON Config, das finde ich schon mal wunderbar,
das ist easy, so, Konsole, speichern wir einfach mal, Null, warum ist das Null, ok, Dis Monitor,
Active, also, das haben wir, Target, Active, ok, das ist das Config Objekt für so eine,
für so ein Check, Type, Push, Tags, ich denke mal, ich kann jetzt hier nicht einfach irgendwas
eintragen, oder, also, wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel sagen würde, keine Ahnung, This Monitor
Tag W gleich 1, das wird dann wahrscheinlich nicht so ganz funktionieren, Save, Lock, das
würde mich jetzt äußerst wundern, wenn das funktioniert, ne, das wäre es jetzt auch,
ok, wo kommt denn das Zeug her, This, This Monitor, if this, oh, das ist mir zu hoch,
ok, das ist die Benachrichtigung, wenn es geklappt hat, wo schiebt das denn jetzt an
in Server, Submit, ist Input valid, ok, Utifile, String, hier, This Refs Tags Manager, Submit,
Push, hier, ne, wo sendet er denn die Edit Monitor hier, wo sendet er denn die Sachen
zum Server, das verstehe ich jetzt nicht, das leuchtet mir gerade nicht ein, er muss
doch irgendwo das Konfig zum Server schicken, oder nicht, ich heiße jetzt Test1, save, was,
das kann doch nicht nur kleinzeitig gespeichert sein, das wäre doch total bescheuert, ach,
das geht über ein Websocket, das geht über ein Websocket, deswegen steht es da drinnen,
deswegen das geht hier über den Websocket, aha, hier, Emit, Edit und auf dem Serverseite
ist er irgendwie Subscribed zu diesem Websocket, Emit, Edit, This Monitor, also, dann gehen
wir mal hier, Log, This Monitor, Konsole, save, aha, gut, aber da kann ich jetzt trotzdem
nicht einfach irgendwas dran heften, oder, lull, das wird doch nicht funktionieren, save,
wir schauen einfach mal in die Datenbank rein, wir schauen einfach mal in die Datenbank rein,
ob da irgendwas, äh, Data wahrscheinlich, SQLite Browser, HumaDB, so, ach du Scheiße,
komm, was heißt schon Fuck, nein, das heißt Foreign Key, aber ich denke, es steht für
Fuck, so, Heartbeat Monitor, Monitor Notification, Browse Data, oh, wie hat man denn jetzt ewig
her, dass der mit was gemacht hat, wie hat man das denn jetzt verwendet, Monitor, Browse
Data, Heartbeat Monitor, hier, ok, da kann man nicht einfach irgendwas eintragen, weil,
wenn ich da irgendwas eintrage, dann gibt es das nicht, wobei Body Headers, na Moment,
Body Headers, es ist ja für die, wenn du HTTP verwendest, ich mein, ich könnte, ich könnte
irgendein Feld da jetzt einfach für benutzen, was man beim Push-Check nicht braucht, wobei
das halt wirklich hardcore ppeger ist, na, man könnte, man könnte zum Beispiel, man
könnte zum Beispiel, keine Ahnung, Headers irgendwie dafür benutzen, aber das ist nicht,
das ist nicht schön, ok, irgendwas eintragen kann ich da auf jeden Fall nichts, weil das
alles in der Datenbank drinstehen muss, dann, dann lassen wir das erstmal, machen wir die
allereinfachste Variante, wir übergeben das einfach in der Message, guckt mal, wir können
doch hier, wir können doch hier in der Message aktuell schicken wir hier Message, ok, aber
man könnte doch einfach, das machen wir jetzt hier einfach, das machen wir jetzt hier mal,
das kommt wieder weg, ne, ich mach das rückgängig nicht, da ich da irgendwelche komischen Commits
drinne hab, die ich nicht haben will, Details, so, wo, was passiert bei der neuen Message,
wo wird das angezeigt, Data, Monitor, Datenbank Schema anpassen, ne, also wenn ich irgendwie
realistische Chancen haben will, dass das gemerged wird, das können das 15 Zeilen sein
oder so und es darf auch nicht total eklig sein, so, Ping, Mounted, macht er in Mounted
was, Mounted, ne, macht er nix, äh, könnte man das jetzt zum Beispiel machen, Monitor,
Last, Last Heartbeat, Ping, ok, ähm, wir machen mal hier ein, nur mal so aus, wir machen
ein extra computed hin, für, äh, ich nenne es jetzt einfach mal Unit, auch wenn es nicht
passt, einfach zum checken, ähm, und das gehen wir hier wegnehmen, das hier zumachen,
Dashboard, genau, so, und dann geben wir das einfach mal irgendwo auf der Seite aus, um
zu gucken, ob es funktioniert, was weiß ich hier oben, so, ne, View sind immer zwei, ne,
Unit, Data, Unit, Return, Lul, da, ok, so, also, was haben wir denn hier, Heartbeat List,
was steht denn da drinne, nix, ah ne, this, das ist ein View, aha, ok, was steht drinne,
Monitor, ID, Status, Time, Message, Message ist das, was ich haben will, Ping, ok, also,
dann versuchen wir nochmal was in diese Message, in diese Message zu packen, so, ich kann jetzt
da nicht einfach ein JSON-Objekt reinpappen, aber, äh, ich kann ein JSON-Objekt, JSON
World Encode, oder Tool, jawoll, irgendwas, so, also, was, was, was könnten wir denn da
reinschreiben, wir brauchen ein, eine, eine Unit, Gigabyte oder so, Moment, das ist JSON-gültig
nur so, und eine, keine Description, irgendwie sowas, Unit, Description, das ist dann, keine
Ahnung, Disk, GB, oh ja, exzellent, das wollte ich auch schon immer mal zu einem Server schicken,
wobei braucht man das überhaupt bei, das, eigentlich reicht noch Description, und Message,
eine Message dabei, Brege, ja, Message brauchen wir auch noch, was soll das, Message, Standard,
Standard Message ist, äh, ok, äh, äh, keine Ahnung, genug Platz, Speicherplatz, nachdem
das ja was ist, was User Supplied ist, müssen wir das auch nicht übersetzen, oder nicht
Translate, weil die Leute werden ja, werden ja schon wissen, was sie da reinschreiben,
so, Message, genug Speicherplatz, Unit, Gigabyte, Description, Disk, bin mir gar nicht sicher,
ob wir beides brauchen, vielleicht, vielleicht reicht, na doch, beides ist schon, ist, ist
wahrscheinlich besser, so, und jetzt nehmen wir das mal, und jetzt wird's super hübsch,
Komma, fehlt, echt, ah, hier fehlt, Komma, tatsächlich, Pequate, While, ok, dann hauen
wir das hier mal rein, anstatt die Message, und jetzt gucken wir mal schnell, Bäm, unser
Jason kommt da auf jeden Fall schon mal an, hier, Message, genug Speicherplatz, Unit,
GB, Description, Disk, so, jetzt ist natürlich die Frage, möchten wir jetzt unten in der
Message nur Message anzeigen lassen, das ist aber erstmal wurscht, so, this heartbeat list,
steht es jetzt da irgendwo drinnen, Monitor, genug Speicherplatz, Unit, ja, das steht da
drinnen, das könnten wir jetzt eigentlich einfach pasen, was passiert denn, wenn das
down geht, dann steht einfach nur drinnen, no heartbeat in the time window, das heißt,
wir müssen jetzt erstmal schauen, dass wir uns den letzten, den letzten Eintrag raussuchen,
der Status up hat, weil Status down ist was, was vom System gehandelt wird, da ist halt
einfach ein String drinnen, und nicht unser komisches Jason-Objekt, Azulet, was soll
ich last up, find, wir machen schon mal hier die Tools, ich muss das mal ein bisschen kleiner
machen, sonst finde ich hier nichts mehr, so, und wir schreiben das wieder raus da oben,
ups, so, Unit, find, so find, heartbeat, wo heartbeat, achso, wie heißt das eigentlich,
up up oder down ist, lul, log, this heartbeat list, na super, muss ich nochmal rückgängig
machen, geil, ach, sehr gut, sehr gut gemacht, big brain time, sehr schlau, äh, Status,
Status 1, Status 0, ok, also wir suchen alle, wir suchen den letzten heartbeat, der Status
1 hatte, so, und dann gehen wir den mal aus, ne, also, ähm, wir suchen den letzten Status,
den letzten heartbeat Status, der 1 hatte, und dann sagen wir Jason pass, last up message,
das funktioniert, da bin ich jetzt mal gespannt, ob das tut, ok, es hat schon mal kein Fehler
gegeben, wir müssen die Unit hier unten ja noch irgendwo reinschreiben, äh, wie ist
das Ding, count, count up, hier, Unit, Unit, Unit ist jetzt, Unit, oh, broken, read und
find, ja gut, ach und find, ich muss erstmal gucken, ob da noch was drin ist, if not last
up, dann ist die Unit Millisekunden, das soll ja defaultmäßig alles bleiben, wie es ist,
dann ist es Millisekunden, ok, Jason pass message, äh, message object, mir fällt jetzt
nichts besseres für ein, return message object, Unit, gb, bam, heißt das Ding, jetzt heißt
das Ding, jetzt Unit gb, das ist doch schon mal gut, das gefällt mir, so magic, magic
message string, natürlich könnte das jetzt auch fehlschlagen, wenn einer merkwürdig
formatiertes Zeugs, ähm, nachdem das ja nicht mein eigener Kram ist, müssen wir das wahrscheinlich
auch noch ein bisschen Fehlerbehandlung rein machen, ähm, keine Ahnung, Jason pass, wenn
das funktioniert, einfach return Unit und ansonsten return MS oder so, by the way wir
können uns das wahrscheinlich komplett sparen, weil der Fehler geht auch so, ja, ok, hey
Max, anderes Thema, glaubst du Battlefield bekommt nächstes Jahr noch die Kurve, nö,
kannst dir mein letztes Video angucken, ich gehe nicht davon aus, dass das irgendwie
noch, ähm, in irgendeiner Art und Weise da sinnvoll was rumkommt, ich glaube das ist
in Brunnen gefallen, da kommt nix mehr, ok, also entweder haben wir ne Message, wo was
drinnen steht, weil holen wir uns Unit raus, wenn einer falsch formatiertes Jason schickt,
ist er selbst dran schuld, dann ist die default Unit halt weiterhin Millisekunden, vollkommen
in Ordnung, ähm, jetzt brauchen wir das gleiche nochmal für Description oder so, das ist
zwar nicht schön das zu copypasten, aber zum ausprobieren, das kann man dann immer
noch schöner machen, Description ist, wie habe ich es genannt, Desk, Desk, genau, äh,
Standard Description gibt es nicht, achso doch, Standard Description ist, äh, nix, nix,
irgendwie so, ok, dann gucken wir mal, dass wir das angepasst kriegen, ich mach das mal
ein bisschen größer, wir machen es erstmal nur mit der Unit, da muss ich irgendwas schöneres
überlegen, so, jetzt könnte man nämlich hier runter gehen, wie ist das denn, Count, irgendwas
mit Count Up, dann sagen wir jetzt einfach Value, Unit, Unit, guck mal, und als das hier
schon mal, dann ist das hier schon mal Gigabyte und das hier ist auch Gigabyte, jetzt gehen
wir in das Chart, jetzt gehen wir in das Chart und das Chart braucht auch, wie ist das, Ping,
Ping Chart, das kriegt auch Unit schon übergeben, aber es ist immer noch MS, ach nee, Moment,
Ping, Ping Chart, da, Unit, Unit, jetzt ist es auch Gigabyte, guck mal, und jetzt ergibt
es auch gleich viel mehr Sinn, es sind halt einfach jetzt, ach da stehen auch Millisekunden
dabei, ok, Ping Chart, irgendwas MS, Unit, this Unit, so guck mal, und schon haben wir
aus dem Ping Chart ein, so viel Festplattenspeicher ist noch frei Chart gemacht und Up und Down
funktioniert immer noch, ich meine, das sind randomized Werte, ja, kein Wunder, dass das
so ein bisschen fail aussieht, und das sind jetzt aktuell nur, ich glaube, fünf Zeilen
oder so, nein, bisschen mehr haben wir schon geändert, jetzt diff, naja, hält sich doch
äußerst den Grenzen, oder, so, dann müssen wir uns mal was schönes überlegen, weil das
Ding soll ja nicht weiter Ping heißen, sondern, das soll, Ping, Titel hieß das, na, Ping,
Ping Titel, Moin, Kengin, so, das soll ja nicht Ping Titel sein, sondern jetzt sowas
hier, Disk, GB, warum bauen wir Grafana Prometheus nach, wir bauen das nicht nach, wir patchen
was, was schon da ist, nur mit dem Unterschied, dass du hiermit gescheites Up und Down Monitoring
machen kannst mit einem gescheiten GUI, anstatt wo du von Hand was einrichten musst wie Prometheus,
also du brauchst keinen Prometheus, du brauchst keinen Nodexporter, du brauchst keinen Grafana,
du brauchst keinen Alertmanager, du hast alles in einem, das einzige, was mir bei Uptime
Kuma fehlt, ist, dass du eine Anzeige hast für abgelaufene Zertifikate und dass du bei
den Push Notifications was anderes als Ping mit schicken kannst, und das versuche ich
gerade zu bauen, du kannst es halt nicht, weil ganz ehrlich, wenn ich ne Kiste habe,
die selbst diesen Ping Parameter setzen kann, die Kiste weiß den Ping doch gar nicht, den
er pusht, das heißt Ping überhaupt da als Parameter zu haben ist sinnlos, deswegen kann
man Ping einfach für irgendwas anderes verwenden, und in dem Fall zum Beispiel für Disk Space,
immer so, guck mal Leute, so ist das doch richtig nice, jetzt hat man die Möglichkeit
jedes x-beliebige, jeden x-beliebigen Wert mitzuschicken, das müssen wir jetzt noch
bauen, dass das mit Disk, dass er aktuell Hardcoded, aber man hat die Möglichkeit jeden
x-beliebigen Wert mitzuschicken, jetzt können wir uns nur noch überlegen, ob es vielleicht
schöner wäre, Chat was meinen ihr, soll bei Message einfach der komplette JSON String
angezeigt werden oder sollen wir bei Message, falls es ein JSON Objekt ist, einfach nur
das aus dem Message Ding anzeigen lassen, wahrscheinlich ist das besser, wir zeigen da unten nur an,
was in Message drin steht, ich versuche das als Pull Request einzureichen, keine Ahnung
ob das, was das für Chancen hat, es war ja eben jemand auch schon im Stream da, der
hatte schon öfters was, öfters was Contributed und der ist gerade sehr beschäftigt, Leute
ganz kurz, Sack, Sack, ich muss mal kurz aufs Klo.
Sack.
So, wieder da, Jason im Frontend sieht aus wie ein Fehler, ja das stimmt, das sollten
wir anders machen, guck mal das Ding hier unten heißt schon Message, wir zeigen da
nur Message ein, genug Speicherplatz, so, also wie kriegen wir da unten am besten die
Message raus, wo wird das überhaupt eingetragen, Details, Message, Message, hier Table, Table
Borderless, Table Hover, ich versuch da ne Bröderquest raus zu machen, ja, so, was willst
du reinpatchen, ich hab schon reingepatcht, dass du anstatt Ping beliebige andere Werte
anzeigen lassen kannst, guck jetzt kannst du beispielsweise standardmäßig, siehst
es ja hier bis es geladen ist, steht dann da Response Time, Millisekunden und sowas,
aber sobald die Seite geladen ist, wechselt es auf Gigabyte, Gigabyte und Disk, und du
musst eigentlich kaum was ändern, das sind bloß 5 Zeilen oder so, das geht natürlich
nur für dieses Push Monitoring, wo du halt selbst Bescheid sagst alle 60 Sekunden, dass
es da ist, so, wo wird das denn hier unten eingetragen, Message, Table Content, Message,
Beat Index, Displayed Records, hier Beat Message ist es oder, was Class, Not Beat Message, was,
was passieren hier für Dinger, Not Beat Message, ah das ist wenns leer ist, wenns leer ist
dann, ok was auch immer da passiert, hier ist die Message, Cookplus, KegWee, ja, also
sprich wir müssen jetzt hier sowas machen wie Jason Pass, das machen wir aber nicht
hier inline drinne, Jason Pass, Message, Message, das ist das hässlichste glaube ich was man
so machen kann, ausprocken, ja da sind ja auch andere Sachen drin, da brauchen wir jetzt
eine extra Methode für würde ich sagen, dass das ordentlich funktioniert, da muss ich mir
noch was schönes überlegen, Mars, Message, das ist noch ein View 2 Projekt, Beat, so,
Pass, Message, nee Beat Message, so, Extract Message String, kann man, dann weiß man eher
was es macht, oh das ist unübersichtlich, Message, Message, ja, so, also da müssen wir
jetzt auch sagen, ok Try, Wenn, Wenn, Jason Pass, was ist cool, das ist ein Uptime Monitoring
Tool für deine Server, das ist nicht von mir, das ist von, hier, Louis Lam, wo das anfängt
und aufhört beim Namen, der hat das vor einem Jahr oder so glaube ich gestartet, das geht
mega gut ab auf GitHub, 11.000 Sterne, also das ist richtig massiv, krass, geiles, also
riesen, riesen Ding mittlerweile und damit kannst du verschiedene Services überwachen,
ob deine Server offline sind oder online sind, du kannst gucken, ob deine Datenbank noch
antwortet, Port Checks, DNS Auflösung und sonst was und was mir halt fehlt, ist noch
die Möglichkeit, dass man relativ einfach mit einer Push Notification, was anderes
als Ping anzeigen lassen kann, zum Beispiel hier Disk Space, so Pass, Message, wenn das
funktioniert, dann gibt es das, Moment, Moment, das muss ich anders machen, ach wobei, so
und wenn es einen Fehler gibt, dann geben wir einfach nur Message zurück, funktioniert
das jetzt, ja guck mal genug Speicherplatz, jetzt sieht es nicht mehr so hässlich aus,
das ist doch richtig nice, mehr müssen wir dafür gar nicht machen
denke ich, ja wunderbar, so und jetzt müssen wir uns nur noch überlegen, wie man hier
Disk, wie man das für den Ping Titel irgendwie ordentlich dahin bekommt, Unit, ja weil da
ist eigentlich noch mehr drin, was ist Abteil Kuma, was zum Server überwachen, mit 11.000
Sternen auf GitHub, was nicht so kompliziert zu konfigurieren ist wie SubX oder Nagios oder
sonst was und viel weniger kann, bei den Current Disk fehlt noch das GB, was, wo, hä, das
ist, nein das ist Vue.js, also ich glaube ich werde heute Nacht online sein, aber versprechen
tue ich ja nichts, das hier buggt anscheinend rum, fragt mich nicht warum, warum buggt das
eigentlich rum, wenn was neues geschickt wird, guck mal hier funktioniert es aber sobald
was neues geschickt wird, ist kaputt, warum, weil, ist num, ist num, else, ok das heißt
das ist keine Nummer Javascript, alles klar, dann, ok jetzt wirds Javascriptisch, zeig
mal her, ist num, ist num, ja, lock, value, value ist das ne, value, ne, this value, wir
type of this value, string, ok, ach ne ein, hä, 8, 848 ist ne String und das andere ist
ne Nummer, das liegt nicht an der Sache, die ich zum Server schicke, es funktioniert, wenn
es aus der Datenbank kommt, aber wenn es live eingeliefert wird, wird es über den Socket,
das ist ein Bug, das ist wahrscheinlich ein Bug, das ist wahrscheinlich ein Bug, das wird
nicht zu ner Nummer konvertiert, wenn es über den Socket reinkommt und das werde ich jetzt
nicht fixen, das werde ich jetzt nicht fixen, weil das ne ganz andere Stelle ist, es funktioniert
ja, das ist ein Bug, der nicht an mir liegt, da mach ich jetzt auch nix, das las ich einfach
so, da würd ich lieber nen eigenen Bug fix machen, für nicht hier mit reinwursten, wenn
es über den Socket rübergeschickt wird, wird es nicht zu nem Int gepasst vorher, so, so
jetzt müssen wir aber noch schauen, wie wir das hinkriegen, dass dieses DiskGB, also die
Unit, extrahiert der ja schon ganz gut, wir machen nicht Unit, wir machen computed, uncomputed,
wie nennt man das, data ist dumm, custom, values oder so, ne, wie nennt man das, wie könnte
man das nennen, was ich da übergebe, Parameter, irgendwie sowas, das ist ja Zusatzdinger,
die muss man nicht übergeben, custom, so, irgendwie sowas, so und dann returnen wir
auch hier das, das, das Object, ok, weil ihr es seid, Black Ops, ja, das sag ich öfters
mal, Leute, dass sie schon seit Black Ops am Start sind,
hat das so eigentlich ganz ok, das dumme ist, dass man das halt duplizieren müsste,
das müsste man halt dafür duplizieren, was sicherlich nicht gut ankommt, aber es wäre
nicht Unit, sondern es wäre Desk in dem Fall und die Fall gibt es nix, so und da können
wir jetzt sagen, DiskGB ist, so und da können wir jetzt einfach schauen, if this unit description,
dann returnen wir, kann man das kürzer schreiben in JavaScript, jetzt funktioniert es nämlich,
weil ansonsten heißt Ping, wie funktioniert das Push auf dem Client, du machst nen Curl,
du musst nen Curl machen auf den Server hier unter api push, dann kriegst du so nen Token
und darauf musst du dann quasi nur nen gültigen, du musst alle 60 Sekunden gültigen Request
schicken, sonst geht es hier auf rot, Blitzchak, danke für den Sub, stimmt, stimmt, woher
weißt du, ob das ich das bin, wir könnten das aber eigentlich so mal gucken, Unit, man
kann aber nicht sowas machen, JavaScript Logik, wirst es nicht auch gehen, doch ne, das wirst
doch eigentlich so auch gehen, also wir returnen die Unit Description, das ist erst beim Laden,
dass es beim Laden nicht da ist, das ist normal, da können wir aber nichts dran ändern, weil
der erstmal die Objekte laden muss und nur wenn er die Objekte geladen hat, dann findet
er eventuell Konfig, die er hier anzeigen kann, damit müssen wir glaub ich leben, ansonsten
müssten wir das in den Settings Dialog machen, ja das könnt ihr über Kon zum Beispiel schicken,
alle 60 Sekunden, ich finde das eigentlich ganz nice, guck mal, jetzt kann ich was ich
will zum Server schicken, ne, also zum Beispiel, ist halt mega eklig hier, ähm, ja, das ist
super, zum Beispiel, alles mit dem random, machen wir jetzt mal hier, keine Ahnung, 20,
kopiere das jetzt hier rüber, dass man es jetzt hier mal live sieht, so perfekt, so kennt
jemand ein schönes Tool für Url-Encode in der Shell, Url-Encode Shell One Liner oder
so, Url-Encode Shell One Liner, how to Url-Encode Data, aha, wait a minute, Curl kann das schon,
August, ey guck mal, Curl ist richtig 11 head wieder, richtig big brain das ganze Ding,
nice, Curl kann das schon, Curl, bam, Url-Encode, also Url-Encode, Moment, das müssen wir
Single Quoten, sonst funktioniert das nicht, Url-Encode, was habe ich gesagt, brauche
mal Message, dann brauchen wir, mal nachgucken, Unit, machen wir jetzt mal was anderes, Unit,
Celsius, weil, mal gucken, ob es funktioniert, könnte ja sonst was sein, vielleicht die Raumtemperatur
von irgendwo, und jetzt brauchen wir noch Desk, Desk ist Raumtemperatur, du hast Message
gleich vergessen, ach ja, habe ich tatsächlich, Message gleich, und das funktioniert jetzt
mit Url-Encode, da bin ich jetzt mal gespannt, nö, bam, ach Post, nee, Moment, ich will
den Get machen, was, Minus G, was macht Minus G, man, Curl, jetzt lernen wir wieder was,
Minus G, Get, okay, ach, der will mitdenken, der will mitdenken und macht ein Post, Ups,
jetzt habe ich doppelt gepostet, ja, Minus G, ich glaube, das hat funktioniert, nee, doch,
ich glaube, mein Url-Encode-Zeug funktioniert nicht, woher weiß ich jetzt, dass es klappt,
gibt es irgendwie einen Verbose oder so, dass ich weiß, was der schickt, er schickt, Get,
Copy, Push, Message, das sieht Url-Encoded aus, aber der Ping fehlt jetzt, nee, ich kann,
ich kann das einfach so ändern, wie ich will, weil der immer die letzte Message für die
Unit nimmt, ich meine, wir haben jetzt halt auf einmal dann 30.000 Grad, ich meine, gut,
kann ich mitleben, jetzt weiß ich nicht, ob es nicht funktioniert, wir müssen uns, wir
müssen uns das ausgeben lassen, äh, wo hatte ich das denn eben hier, hier oben, hier oben
hatte ich es eingetragen, ist das List, Heartbeat-List, glaube, wenn ich gucken, Message, nope, ähm,
mein Url-Encode ist nicht richtig, mein Jason ist richtig, oder, Message gleich, nee, muss
ich nicht, das funktioniert, guck, das ist eigentlich okay, das kommt auch an, es kommt
auch an, aber der checkt das mit der Message nicht, warum nicht, da können wir uns doch
jetzt mal ausgeben lassen, wenn was Neues ankommt, wie gebe ich mir dann jetzt was aus,
wenn was Neues ankommt, vielleicht hier, Compute, Compute Last Heartbeat, das geht gut, Lock,
Pass, This, Monitor, genau das da, das, das, das sieht so aus, genau das will ich haben,
eh, funktioniert doch, Message, lull, Unit, Celsius, okay, dann ist meine Logik kaputt,
dann funktioniert es von der Idee her, aber meine Logik ist broken, meine Logik ist kaputt,
warum ist meine Logik kaputt, Anzeige ist raus, Last Up, Last Up, ah, Moment, ah, macht
es das andersrum vielleicht, muss ich das reverse machen, dass es gar nicht sortiert
ist nach, vielleicht ist das gar nicht sortiert, nee, nee, der kann das nicht, hä, der kriegt
den Parameter nicht, okay, irgendwie, mein Curl ist im Arsch, was hab ich übersehen
Chat, nee, hab ich nicht, mein Curl ist kaputt, also wir können es jetzt mal anders ausprobieren,
ich machs jetzt mal hier drüber, Message ist, keine Ahnung, Temperatur, Temperatur, Unit
ist Celsius, gerade Celsius und Description ist, achso, hab ich Description vergessen,
nee, Temperatur, alles nice zu, Description ist Temperatur, ist das das gleiche, wie ich
hier verschicke, das muss ich jetzt mal kurz checken, Message 7B22L, sieht eigentlich relativ
gut aus, okay, dann bin ich mir nicht ganz sicher, warum es nicht funktioniert, so, wenn
es jetzt funktioniert, sollte was mit Temperatur drinstehen, alles nice, nausi, temp, alles
nausi, gut, Temperatur, geht doch, ah, okay, jetzt versteh ich das, es muss einmal down
sein, dass der neue Config annimmt, ja gut, damit kann ich leben, damit, damit kann ich
leben, Temperatur, ja, das, über 24 im Durchschnitt ist vielleicht nicht so, nicht so, nicht
so nice, ja, okay, aber jetzt funktioniert's, jetzt funktioniert's, wir haben jetzt, wir
haben 29.318 Grad, aber okay, why not, ja, why not, und wenn dann dieser Pullrequest
hier durch ist, von diesem einen Kerl, dann kann man den Status nämlich von Hand setzen,
das wäre richtig nice, da könnte ich nämlich hier noch sagen, und, und Status gleich down
oder so, aber gut, das funktioniert, das ist halt die Durchschnittstemperatur oder so,
aber ping ist jetzt noch nötig, ja, weil ping, der immer der Wert ist für die Temperatur,
40 Grad, jetzt haben wir 40 Grad, ping ist der einzige Parameter, den ich für den Wert
verwenden kann, also ping gleich value, das Ding heißt halt, das Ding heißt halt ping,
es ist an so, jetzt sag mal so, es ist an sich schon irgendwie ein bisschen gewachsen,
weil du kannst message angeben und du kannst ping angeben, die message ist eigentlich gedacht
dafür hier unten, aber ping anzugeben macht eigentlich überhaupt keinen Sinn bei einem
Push, also bei einer Push-Meldung, weil der ping, den kannst du ja nicht wissen, wenn
du den Push startest, und der Server kann nicht wissen, wie lange es gedauert hat, das
einzige was ginge ist, dass du eine Absenderzeit reinschreibst, der Server sagt bei sich und
er rechnet das, das ist aber auch schon, also ping ist hier quasi sowas wie value zu sehen
in dem Fall, so, ich mein man könnte das vielleicht auch noch anders machen, zum Beispiel
könnte man auch optional sagen, ok, Description ist halt das, was er dann anzeigt, das ist
das, die Temperatur ist oder Raumtemperatur oder sonst was, wir warten jetzt mal bis das,
ok, mal gucken ob das jetzt funktioniert, Unit, Description, Raum, Raum, einfach Raum
heißt jetzt Raum, ja funktioniert, guck, man muss warten bis das einmal down gegangen
ist, es wäre viel viel cooler, wenn man diese Sachen hier über Settings machen könnte,
aber, dass es über Settings geht, müsste ich Datenbankänderungen machen und da hab
ich Schiss davor, und ich glaube auch das wollen die nicht, so missbrauchen wir halt
jetzt das Messagefeld, und er nimmt immer die letzte Message, die er findet und trägt
davon die Units ein, so, ich mein wir könnten hier bei der Description, wir könnten noch
sowas wie Durchschnitt, was aber Durchschnitt anzeigen soll, falls überhaupt und wenn es
leer ist, lassen wir es weg, weil guck mal, das hier ist quasi Durchschnittstemperatur
über 24 Stunden, ich glaube das ist nicht wirklich sinnig, werden dann beim jedem Push
alle Argumente benötigt oder reicht das einmalig die Einheiten festlegen und danach nur noch
Ping mit senden, das ist eine gute Idee, man könnte sagen, der erste Push ist ein Configuration
Push, das finde ich sogar noch viel cooler, der erste Push ist ein Configuration Push
und wenn ich das halt umstellen will, dann muss ich es löschen, weil mal ganz ehrlich,
wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich, wenn du es so grundlegend umstellst, musst du es eh löschen,
weil ich will doch keine Gigabyte Festplattenplatz umstellen zu Raumtemperatur, das ist doch
sinnlos, ich mein deswegen wäre das halt über die Config Seite viel, viel nicer, aber ich
habe es euch ja eben gezeigt, es gibt ja in der Datenbank, Data, SQLite Browser, es gibt
ja in der Datenbank leider, für sowas sind NoSQL Datenbanken gut, da kannst du einfach
rein scheißen, im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes und es ist da, aber hier, das ist ja alles
super structured, so guckt hier, Browse Data Monitor und das ist die Config für unseren
Monitor Check, Name, Test is active, User ID, Intervall, Url, Typ, ich bräuchte da jetzt
noch zusätzliche Felder für meine Settings, das ist diagonal, horizontal, vertikal, das
ist massive, Kubernetes skalierbar, AWS, Kubernetes Service, skalierbar, wir könnten auch, und
da bin ich mir halt nicht sicher, ob die sowas mögen oder nicht, wir könnten beispielsweise
auch, ich mein das hier ist ja, man sieht es hier, das ist ein Typ, Push, Push Check,
so und ich weiß, dass man beispielsweise für einen Push Check keine Accepted Status Codes
braucht, also man könnte theoretisch dieses Accepted Status Codes ja etwas abwandeln und
für meine Settings verwenden, aber ich glaube, das wollen die nicht haben, vor allem, wenn
es irgendwann mal bei einem Push Notification, vor allem, wenn es bei der Push Notification
auf einmal Accepted Status Codes gibt, es wäre halt cool, wenn es ein Feld gäbe, Custom,
wo du alles drin speichern kannst, was du lustig bist, da hättest du quasi ein No SQL Feld
in einer SQL Datenbank, ich mein in Body und Headers könnte man das noch reinschreiben,
im Body wäre das gar nicht so falsch oder, da müsste man jetzt halt noch ein bisschen
mehr machen, das wäre vielleicht, also, dann müsste man jetzt zum Beispiel hier hergehen
und in den Settings, in den Settings müsste man jetzt halt hier noch zwei Sachen einfügen,
nämlich für Unit und Description, das wäre ja kein Ding und die würde man dann speichern
in, aber das will bestimmt keiner wirklich haben, die würde man dann speichern in Body,
Body und Headers wird glaube ich für HTTP Checks verwendet, z.B. wenn ich HTTP Checks
mache, kann ich, hier, Body, Header, da kann ich quasi sagen, was ist okay als Antwort,
ich glaube nicht, dass man das für, nicht dass man das verwenden sollte für hier sowas,
leider gibt es kein Custom Feld, alles andere würde halt nicht passen, aber ich hab keine
Ahnung, wie man neue Datenbankfelder einfügt, da bin ich viel zu pepega, deswegen finde
ich meine Sachen mit diesem JSON String, den man postet, gar nicht so verkehrt, aber wir
können das echt so machen, wie es der Chat vorgeschlagen hat, der erste Push, ich muss
mal kurz gucken, Lieferando, ob die irgendwas sagen, Lieferando, vielen Dank für deine
Bestellung, ja schön, weiter, verfolge deine Bestellung, Tracking, jawoll, wir haben deine
Lieferzeit 19 Uhr bestätigt, exellent, na, schauen wir mal, kommt safe in 20 Minuten,
eine Stunde vorher, ja vielleicht, so, dann starten wir den Kramer, wieder, zack, guck
jetzt ist wieder Disc, Disc, also, erste Message, okay, da machen wir Find, kann man Find von
hinten machen, da muss ich wahrscheinlich reverse, reverse, gibt es eine schöne, kann man Find
von hinten machen, JavaScript, Find from, from, end of array, use array slice to return a
specific element, nee, nee, ich will ja suchen, last index of, ja, mit reverse bin ich auch
schon drauf gekommen, das ist aber nicht schön, das ist lahm as fuck, du musst das einmal
komplett rumdrehen, nur um dann was zu suchen, du musst aber aufpassen, Artbeats werden da
extra gelöscht, aha, Chat, dann funktioniert das nicht, was wir, dann muss ich, dann muss
ich so lassen, dann muss ich so lassen, der letzte, der letzte Up wird genommen, nee,
da geht's, da geht das nicht, dann geht das nicht, dann muss man, dann muss man jedes
Mal, dann muss man jedes Mal posten, aber ich mein, das geht doch, so, wie viele, wie viele
Sachen haben wir denn jetzt geändert, if, es hält sich doch äußerst in Grenzen, oder,
das sind, ok, das müssen wir anders machen, das ist nicht schön, ansonsten haben wir angepasst,
wenn es, wenn es nicht Default ist, dann, wenn es Default ist, dann nehmen wir das Übersetzte,
ansonsten das Format, wir haben Default eingefügt, wir haben das ersetzt durch die Unit, wir
übergeben Units für den Craft und für die Ping Anzeige und ansonsten, es ist eigentlich
relativ übersichtlich, ich mein, wir haben, ja, das da, was ist das, das sind 30 Zeilen
oder so, da muss ich mal überlegen, ob wir das alles noch irgendwie ein bisschen schöner
hinkriegen, also das, das finde ich auf jeden Fall eklig, dass man das zweimal braucht,
aber das ist so, sag mal so, das ist schon schön in sich, in sich gestanden, ich mach
doch Extract, guck mal, ich mach zweimal das gleich, ich pass das Ding jedes Mal, das kann
doch nicht sein, dass ich das, Moment, das, das, das, das müssen wir, try, pass, message,
so, Moment, das ist.NET Style, glaub, der funktioniert hier nicht, wie macht man Multiple,
kann man im JavaScript irgendwie mehrfach mehrere Werte returnen, ja klar, als, als, als, als
Object irgendwie, ne, aber try, pass, JS, JS, return, multiple values, also in, in,
in C Sharp, ich will, ich will sowas machen in C Sharp, bool, out, bla, bla, bla, gibt
sowas in JavaScript, so, try, pass, message, wir gucken nämlich jetzt einfach, ne, Moment,
das hier ist was ganz, was anderes, was ich da probier, ne, das ist was ganz, was anderes,
ne, ne, ist es nicht, so, dann könnte man den Spaß nämlich schon mal, dadurch, dadurch
ersetzen, jetzt muss ich halt irgendwie raus bekommen, ob, ob try, pass, message funktioniert
hat, gibt's da irgendeine, gibt's da irgendwas, was, was, was, was sinnvoll ist für, also
die Sache ist halt, die message kann halt ein normaler String sein ohne JSON drinnen,
dann will ich den normalen String ohne JSON verwenden und sonst nix machen, oder halt
das, das, das Objekt, bool, message, genau, gibt, gibt sowas, gibt es, gibt es sowas
in JavaScript, ne, sowas, Moment, was genau wäre das denn, ne, das sind einfach zwei,
das sind einfach zwei verschiedene Ausdrücke, ne, das, die man nacheinander ausführt, am
Ende bleibt da nur Test, ja, ich mein, ich kann es, ich kann es als Objekt zurückgeben,
das wird funktionieren, ist das, ist das, ist das JavaScript Style, oder, wie würde
man das, wie würde man das JavaScript Style machen, weil ich hab hier im Prinzip JS Optional,
das gibt's, sag mal, ich hab hier auf jeden Fall immer nen Return Wert, es ist entweder
das, was im Message drin steht, ne, ich mein, wir könnten, wir könnten die JavaScript-Geschichte
machen, du kannst ja unterschiedliche Sachen returnen, return false, das ist einfach sagen,
message, so, oder message, weil jetzt wird, das wird funktionieren, so, und dann kannst
du das da oben auch verwenden, oh ne, das funktioniert nicht, das funktioniert nicht,
warum nicht, äh, äh, warum nicht, ah, mhm, weil Punkt Message fehlt, ja, ja, ja, ja,
muss ich das so machen, oder so, Alter, wie macht man ein richtiges JavaScript, wie funktioniert
das, Alter, ist das doch mega hässlicher Shit, alles, oder, message, message, message, das
versteht doch kein Mensch, was da passiert ist, message payload, so, man muss das ja
auch irgendwie verstehen können, mhm, okay, ich hab ne Idee, mhm, so, wir gucken jetzt
einfach, so, das gibt das, ne, das funktioniert nicht, es muss null sein, dass das funzt,
how aus der nicht, jason, message, ein object und greif immer mit message, ne, da müsste
ich zu viel ändern, wobei, eigentlich, mhm, geht das, weil ich hab hier unten, hier unten
brauche, ich brauche das, ich brauche das ja eigentlich nur einmal, ich brauche das
hier unten eigentlich ja nur einmal, so, machen das einfach so, ne, da fällt mir jetzt nichts
gescheites zu einem, zumindest, die eigentliche Sache, die ich machen wollte, funktioniert,
nämlich, wir können das Ding verwenden für andere Sachen, das finde ich schonmal äußerst
nice, so, wie ich das jetzt noch in irgendeiner Variante hübsch mache, dass es besser ankommt,
muss ich mir ja, muss ich mir noch überlegen, die benahmung ist schonmal okay, ich mein,
wir könnten, wir könnten sogar, richtig, richtig massive brain, wir könnten da sogar,
wie macht man multiline dinger in javascript, so, wir könnten da sogar comments rein machen,
seht euch das mal vor, wir haben comments, ja, wie viele jahre, also ich hab mal mit
csharp angefangen, 2002 oder so rum, als dotnet 2 gerade ganz neu war, so, message, lux, ok,
ohne emojis geht hier nix, so, perfekt, ich bin gar nicht sicher, ob man da überhaupt
emojis anzeigen lassen kann drin, ich sollte auch nicht einfach das Ding returnen, ich
sollte gucken, ich sollte das überprüfen, ob das Kunst, also ich sollte überprüfen,
ob das da drin steht, was da drin stehen soll, auf der anderen seite, wenn eine jason objekte
mit schickt, wo irgendwie müll drin steht, ist ja auch nicht wild, dann wird das halt
so, das versteht man wahrscheinlich besser, wofür es da ist, ach, keine ahnung, chat,
die eigentliche sache hat funktioniert, ich hab mich da ein bisschen durchgekämpft, ich
guck mir jetzt noch an, dass ich das irgendwie hübsch mach, dass ich ein pull request auf
machen kann, ich benutze gar nicht view 2, das github-projekt ist in view 2, guck mal,
das da, da kann ich nix dran ändern, oder meint ihr, meint ihr, ein pull request würde
gut ankommen, wo ich ein view update mache auf 3, erstmal kurz alle dateien ändern,
framework austauschen, mal ganz einfach abgesehen, dass das gar nicht lauffähig wäre, was
ich da wahrscheinlich, genau, view, ich würde das einfach umstellen, view shit migrated
to jquery, so, ich bin nachher wahrscheinlich nochmal on, Leute, so dann bis 24 Uhr oder
so, mal gucken, silverlight, perfekt, wir sehen uns bis dann, machts gut, cu.